Hey there, Shankar here. I'm crisscrossing the country for a series of live shows this summer. I'll be sharing seven key insights from the first decade of Hidden Brain. These ideas have made my life better. I think they'll do the same for you. Stops on what I'm calling the Perceptions Tour include Clearwater and Fort Lauderdale in Florida, Portland and Denver, Minneapolis and Chicago, Austin and Dallas, Boston, Toronto, Phoenix and more. To see if I'm coming to a city near you, please visit hiddenbrain.org slash tour. If you've heard my voice for years, it's going to
大家好，我是尚卡尔。今年夏天，我正在全美各地进行一系列现场巡演。我将分享“隐藏的大脑”开播第一个十年总结出的七个关键见解。这些观点让我的生活变得更美好。我想它们对你也会有所帮助。我称之为“感知之旅”的巡演经停站包括佛罗里达州的克利尔沃特和劳德代尔堡、波特兰和丹佛、明尼阿波利斯和芝加哥、奥斯汀和达拉斯、波士顿、多伦多、菲尼克斯等等。想知道我会不会去你所在的城市，请访问 hiddenbrain.org 斜杠 tour。如果你多年来一直听我的声音，那么
be fun to come see me in person. Again, that's hiddenbrain.org slash T-O-U-R. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. Some years ago, psychologists at the University of Virginia and Harvard put people in an empty room. They gave the volunteers a simple task. Sit quietly for a few minutes without distractions. No phone, no books, nothing to do but think. Before the session, the study participants were also given a device. It could deliver a mild electric shock. Using it was not necessary, it was completely optional. The results were, well, shocking. The majority of men, and a quarter of the women,
亲眼见到我一定会很有趣。再说一遍，网址是 hiddenbrain.org 斜杠 T-O-U-R。这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。几年前，弗吉尼亚大学和哈佛大学的心理学家把人们安排在一个空房间里。他们给志愿者布置了一个简单的任务：在没有干扰的情况下静静地坐几分钟。没有手机，没有书，除了思考什么都不用做。在实验开始前，研究参与者还拿到了一台设备。它能释放轻微的电击。使用它并不是必须的，完全是自愿的。结果，怎么说呢，令人震惊。大多数男性和四分之一的女性
chose to shock themselves rather than sit in silence. This held true even after they rated the shock as painful. We are led to believe in everything we hear and read, that suffering is unpleasant, something to be avoided. Every ounce of common sense tells us we should avoid something as unpleasant as an electric shock. So what would compel people to voluntarily hurt themselves? Today, we begin a two-part mini-series about the upside of discomfort and the curious pleasure human beings take in seeking out some forms of suffering. When pain becomes pleasure,
宁愿电击自己也不愿枯坐。即使在他们将电击评定为痛苦之后，情况依然如此。我们被我们听到和读到的一切灌输了一种观念，即痛苦是不愉快的，是应该避免的。常识告诉我们，我们应该避开像电击这样令人不快的事情。那么，是什么驱使人们自愿伤害自己呢？今天，我们开始一个关于不适的好处以及人类在寻找某种痛苦时所感到的奇妙快乐的两集迷你剧。当痛苦变成快乐，
this week on Hidden Brain. The year was 1974. Chinatown and Blazing Saddles were in movie theaters around the country. Queen and David Bowie on the radio. James was a high school senior in Toledo, Ohio. He requested that we not use his full name. I was one of those 18-year-old, impulsive, adrenaline-filled guys who just love being social, ran track, but also was on the high school newspaper,
本周收听“隐藏的大脑”。那是 1974 年。“唐人街”和“灼热的马鞍”正在全国各地的电影院热映。皇后乐队和大卫·鲍伊的歌曲在收音机里播放。詹姆斯是俄亥俄州托莱多的一名高中高年级学生。他要求我们不要使用他的全名。我是那种 18 岁、冲动、充满肾上腺素的小伙子，特别喜欢社交，练过田径，还在校报工作，
and lots of good close friends, but just kind of bouncing off the wall kind of guys. There was an unusual fad making its way across the United States at the time. Streaking. Streaking was basically people would run without any clothes through populated areas, which is tennis shoes on typically. And it was sporting events.
有很多要好的密友，但就是那种精力极其旺盛的男生。当时美国正流行着一种不同寻常的风潮：裸奔。裸奔基本上就是人们不穿任何衣服在人口密集的地区奔跑，通常脚上穿着网球鞋。这发生在体育赛事期间。
There was even a song called, they called me the streak. It was a country song and it was like a number one song. ["The Streak"] The song was catchy. James couldn't get it out of his head. Inspired by the growing trend, the 18-year-old gathered up a few friends.
甚至还有一首名为《他们叫我裸奔狂》的歌。那是一首乡村歌曲，曾登顶排行榜单首位。[《裸奔》] 这首歌很洗脑。詹姆斯脑子里一直挥之不去。在这个日益增长的潮流的启发下，这名 18 岁的少年召集了几个朋友。
Together, they came up with a plan. I think a couple of the guys at my church, I think we talked to them initially, and then I think we had another guy from another high school, actually, I remember, and then a third guy was from my school. So I think we started just talking about it. And you know, this small group gathered and we said, let's do this. And so we're
他们一起想出了一个计划。我想我教堂里的几个伙计，我们最初好像跟他们聊过，然后我想我们实际上还有另一个来自另一所高中的伙计，我记得，然后第三个伙计来自我的学校。所以我想我们开始只是谈论它。你知道，这个小群体聚集在一起，我们说，我们干吧。所以我们
going to go to this local mall, very large mall in Toledo and just run through the center part of the mall, which is a very big area. So the center part of the mall, we're going to enter at one specific entrance and exit at another exit. So we knew where the getaway car needed to be, where he needed to drop us off and where he needed to pick us up. James and his friends planned the whole thing
打算去当地的这家商场，托莱多非常大的一个商场，直接穿过商场中央，那里是一个非常大的区域。所以商场的中心部分，我们要从一个特定的入口进去，从另一个出口出来。所以我们知道接应的汽车该停在哪里，他把我们放在哪里以及在哪里接我们。詹姆斯和他的朋友们把整件事计划得
like a bank robbery. But as their excitement grew, they let their plan slip out. Very quickly, word got around. On the big day, James and his friends bundled into the car with a getaway driver. And we arrived at the mall and we all went in fully clothed just to case the joint. When we came into the mall, it was extremely busy, crowded. We actually recognized some people from our school, from our church, and we noticed a
就像抢银行一样。但随着他们的兴奋感增加，他们不小心把计划泄露了出去。消息很快传开了。到了大日子那天，詹姆斯和朋友们挤进了一辆配有接应司机的汽车。我们到达商场后，都穿着衣服进去了，只是为了踩点。当我们走进商场时，里面人非常多，很拥挤。我们实际上认出了我们学校、我们教堂的一些人，还注意到
lot of security guards. So when you walk through the mall initially and you see people whom you know, and you see people from your church, and you see people who are security guards, did a thought cross your mind that perhaps this was not the best idea? You'd think. You would think that would happen, but no, it did not. I think it was more of a challenge. Okay, let's do this. We've got an audience here. You know, let's hit this. James and his four fellow Strikers had what they felt was a foolproof plan to protect their anonymity.
了很多保安。所以当你刚走进商场，看到你认识的人，看到你教堂的人，看到身为保安的人，有没有一个念头闪过，觉得这可能不是个好主意？你本该这么想的。你本以为会这样，但并没有，完全没有。我觉得这更像是一个挑战。好吧，我们干吧。我们这里有观众呢。你知道，我们冲吧。詹姆斯和他的另外四个裸奔同伴觉得他们有一个万无一失的计划来保护自己的匿名性。
They would wear masks. We definitely wanted to cover our faces. So we come out of the mall, get into the car, we get into our sneakers and our masks, that was it. And we go in and the entrance was kind of like a fire exit, I believe. So we got in that way. I can't remember how we actually got into that door. And we were going down this long hallway. And I remember thinking, this hallway is really long. We really wanna just get this done.
他们会戴上面具。我们绝对想遮住脸。所以我们从商场出来，上车，换上运动鞋和面具，就是这样。然后我们走进去，入口有点像火灾逃生通道，我想是的。所以我们就是那样进去的。我不记得我们是怎么进到那扇门里的。我们沿着一条长长的走廊走着。我记得当时在想，这条走廊真长。我们真的只想赶紧搞定。
At this point, you are all completely naked. Yes, sir. You're good. Sneakers and the mask. And we got up to the double doors. I still remember this, the double doors that has the push bar on it, and we all kind of looked at each other and said, okay, one, two, three, and we just burst out.
此时此刻，你们已经一丝不挂了。是的，长官。你懂的。只有运动鞋和面具。我们走到了双扇门前。我至今还记得，带有推杆的双扇门，我们互相看了看，说，好吧，一、二、三，然后我们就冲了出去。
Just burst out of those doors into the crowd, running pell-mell into the crowd. The next moments were sheer adrenaline and pandemonium. Total panic. Just wanting to get out of there as fast as I can. And I knew which direction we had to run because we had walked through it earlier. And so we're running very fast and security guards are trying to get through the crowd.
就这样冲出大门，冲进人群，乱哄哄地冲进人群。接下来的几片刻全是肾上腺素飙升和一片混乱。彻底的恐慌。只想以最快的速度离开那里。我知道我们必须往哪个方向跑，因为我们之前踩过点。所以我们跑得飞快，保安们正试图挤过人群。
So having a large crowd actually helped us keep the security guards away. But there was one point where I was running and a security guard was coming toward me and I had to use a couple of innocent bystanders as kind of a basketball pick. So they kind of caught the security guard and I was able to run around and keep going. And I have no idea if those poor people,
所以拥挤的人群实际上帮我们挡住了保安。但有一次我在奔跑时，一个保安朝我冲来，我不得不把几个无辜的路人当成篮球掩护。所以他们稍微挡住了保安，我得以绕过去继续跑。我完全不知道那些可怜的人，
I just don't know what happened. But that actually saved me. And I was able to keep going and get out of there as fast as we could. But in any group of antelopes being chased by lions, there is always the slow one who gets caught. The guards captured one of the naked runners. I still remember the one gentleman who got tackled
我只是不知道后来发生了什么。但那确实救了我。我得以继续跑，并以最快的速度逃离那里。但是在任何被狮子追赶的羚羊群中，总有跑得慢的那个会被抓到。保安抓住了其中一个裸奔者。我依然记得那个被扑倒并抓住的仁兄
and caught was yelling at us. And I remember kept saying, come back here, come back and help me. And we were like, sorry, our friend, we're out of here. He was marched back through the crowd to the security office, which was up some stairs. So he was kind of the quintessential walk of shame. Totally naked, I mean, just sneakers, his mask. So he was kind of the quintessential walk of shame. Totally naked, I mean, just sneakers, his mask. But I think he actually had his mask, they took his mask off by then too. So everyone knew who he was.
在冲我们大喊。我记得他一直在说，回来这里，回来帮帮我们。而我们却在想：抱歉，朋友，我们溜了。他被押着穿过人群来到位于楼上的保安办公室。所以他有点像在经历典型的“耻辱之旅”。一丝不挂，我的意思是，只有运动鞋和面具。所以他有点像在经历典型的“耻辱之旅”。一丝不挂，我的意思是，只有运动鞋和面具。但我想他当时其实连面具都没了，他们到那时连他的面具也摘掉了。所以每个人都知道他是谁。
What was your feeling as you were running through the mall, James? Was it a sense of just panic, embarrassment? What was going through your head? I think just more panic and just focused on the goal of getting out of there. Just wanting to not get caught. That was it. Don't get caught.
詹姆斯，当你穿梭在商场里时，你是什么感觉？是一种纯粹的恐慌、尴尬吗？你脑子里在想什么？我觉得更多的是恐慌，而且只专注于逃离那里的目标。只想不被抓住。就是这样。别被抓住。
Get out of there. Try to find your way as best you can. That was really it. I wasn't thinking about any repercussions or consequences, of course. Just pure adrenaline, you know, go, go, go, don't get caught, don't get tackled, et cetera. And so the three of you, now, who are remaining,
离开那里。尽可能地找到出路。真的就是这样。我当然没有考虑任何反响或后果。只有纯粹的肾上腺素，你知道，跑、跑、跑，别被抓，别被扑倒，等等。然后你们三个，现在剩下的你们，
sort of burst through the mall doors on the other side. Was the getaway car waiting for you? Yes, exact, thank goodness. There he was and we literally dove into the backseat and just told him to hit it. What I remember is he then ended up taking us back to our own homes while we were getting dressed in the car. So our clothes were still in the car. So we're getting our clothes on in the car and just,
从商场另一侧的门冲了出来。接应的车在等你们吗？是的，没错，谢天谢地。他就在那儿，我们 literalmente（字面意思：简直）一头扎进后座，让他快开车。我记得的是，他接着把我们送回了各自的家，我们在车里换衣服。所以我们的衣服还在车里。所以在车里穿衣服，然后，
yak and high adrenaline, just very verbal with each other. So we're getting our clothes on in the car and just, you know, yakking, you know, high adrenaline, just very verbal with each other. Can't believe we did this. Oh my gosh, did you see how many people were in there? And so and so he got tackled and all, you know, and just go and just, you know, that kind of kind of vibe in the car. Were there any consequences that came from this? Yeah, I guess we could say that.
七嘴八舌，肾上腺素飙升，大家彼此交谈得非常热烈。所以在车里穿衣服，然后，你知道，七嘴八舌，肾上腺素飙升，大家彼此交谈得非常热烈。真不敢相信我们做到了。哦天哪，你看到里面有多少人了吗？某某某被扑倒了什么的，你知道，就那种，你知道，车里就是那种氛围。这有什么后果吗？是的，可以说是有的。
So when I got home, I was pretty adrenaline was up and just kind of thinking, wow, what have I done? But it was crazy, it was interesting and went to bed. And the next day, I was in the kitchen, getting ready for school and my mother came into the room and she was very angry because I thought I had kind of gotten away with this, that my parents wouldn't know about it. Well, she had gotten a call from one of her, from the women that she went to church with
所以当我到家时，肾上腺素相当高，脑子里就在想，哇，我都干了些什么？但这太疯狂了、太有趣了，然后我就上床睡觉了。第二天，我在厨房里准备去上学，我妈妈走进房间，她非常生气，因为我以为自己已经侥幸逃脱了，我的父母不会知道这件事。嗯，她接到了一位朋友的电话，那是她去教堂时认识的一位女性朋友，
who had actually had been there the night before and witnessed this, witnessed everyone running through, including me. So she, yeah, she saw me, all of me. And my mom just could not believe it. Let me take you back for a second. You said you were wearing a mask. So how did anyone spot you? I think several of the other guys had gotten the word out a little bit.
她实际上前一天晚上就在现场并目睹了这一切，目睹了所有人奔跑，包括我。所以她，是的，她看到我了，看光了我。我妈妈简直不敢相信。我带你回到刚才的话题。你说你戴了面具。那怎么会有人认出你呢？我想其他几个伙计把消息泄露出去了一点。
So that's why I think we had a lot of people there who knew us, including this woman, because I think her daughter went to one of the high schools, and I think the daughter heard it, so she passed it on to this woman from the church, and somehow identified me. I think she, it's a good question, how she identified me. She probably knew how tall I was, let's put it that way. We'll leave it at that. And did you try and deny it when your mom brought it up at the table? No, she obviously had a witness, an impeccable witness.
所以这就是为什么我觉得现场有很多认识我们的人，包括这个女人，因为我想她的女儿在其中一所高中上学，而且我想女儿听说了这事，所以她把消息传给了这位教堂的女士，然后不知怎么就认出了我。我想她，这是一个好问题，她是怎么认出我的。她大概知道我有多高吧，我们这么说吧。就留作悬念吧。当你在餐桌上提起这事时，你妈妈质问你，你有没有试图否认？没有，她显然有人证，一个无可挑剔的人证。
And you know, so I just, I had to admit it. I apologize profusely and I don't remember any consequences necessarily. I don't know if I was grounded or anything like that, but yeah. What happened when you got to school? Because, of course, if word of this had gotten out and more, lots of people actually had gone to the mall, essentially not to go to the mall, but to basically see this, see the spectacle, they must have known that it was you who was running through the mall.
你知道，所以我只能承认。我连连道歉，我不记得有什么必然的后果。我不知道自己有没有被禁足之类的，但是，是的。你去学校时发生了什么？因为，当然，如果消息传出去了，而且更多的人，实际上很多人去商场根本不是为了逛街，而是为了看这个奇观，他们一定知道在商场里裸奔的人是你。
What did your friends think? Yeah, I think there was some buzz in high school, if I don't remember it afterwards, and I got a couple of high fives, and maybe a couple of, you're an idiot. It was a mix of that kind of thing. So yeah, the word had gotten out a little bit in the school. When you look back on the incident now, James,
你的朋友们怎么想？是的，我想高中里有一些轰动，如果我没记错的话，事后我得到了几个击掌，可能还有几句“你是个白痴”。是这种混合的反应。所以，是的，消息在学校里传开了一点。詹姆斯，当你现在回想起那起事件时，
do you look back at it fondly? Do you look back at it with regret? Do you look back at it with embarrassment? Maybe a little bit of both, all of those. I think it was, again, the mindset of the 18-year-old at the time who wanted just to take a chance. Maybe it's just the allure of, I gotta try this. It's way out of my comfort zone. It's unknowable actually, until it's a testing of oneself to see if this really could get away with it. How would that feel? All those kind of things went into this as well. And probably, I don't know, I won't speak for everybody, How would that feel? All those kind of things went into this as well.
你是带着喜爱的心情回想？还是带着后悔的心情？还是带着尴尬的心情？也许两者都有点吧，所有这些情绪都有。我想，这再次体现了当时 18 岁少年只想冒险的心态。也许这就是“我必须试试这个”的诱惑。这远远超出了我的舒适区。其实这是未知的，直到去测试一下自己是否真的能侥幸逃脱。那种感觉会是怎样的？所有这些想法也都包含在其中。可能吧，我不知道，我不会替所有人代言，那种感觉会是怎样的？所有这些想法也都包含在其中。
And probably, I don't know, I won't speak for everybody, but probably not thinking less of consequences and more of what's this experience going to be like? What could this possibly be like? What compels us to do embarrassing things, like run naked through a crowded mall of people we know? And what does streaking have in common with horror movies, spicy food, and mild electric shocks? The answers when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. We generally think of pain and suffering as something to be avoided.
而且可能，我不知道，我不会替所有人代言，但可能考虑后果较少，更多的是在想这段经历会是什么样？这到底会是怎样的体验？是什么驱使我们去做尴尬的事情，比如在一个挤满认识的人的拥挤商场里裸奔？裸奔和恐怖电影、辛辣食物以及轻微电击有什么共同之处？广告回来后为您揭晓答案。您正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。我们通常认为痛苦和折磨是应该避免的事情。
See a sharp thorn on a bush? Don't touch it. Scary movie on TV? Change the channel. A menu item with five peppers in front of it? No thank you. At the University of Toronto, psychologist Paul Bloom says that as much as we are wired to avoid these experiences, we may also be wired to seek them out. Paul Bloom, welcome to Hidden Brain. It's great to be here, Shankar. Looking forward to talking. Paul, we just heard from a man named James, who against all better judgment decided to run naked through a mall with his buddies when he was in high school. Now, I'm assuming
看到灌木丛上有尖刺？不要碰它。电视上有恐怖电影？换台。菜单上有五个辣椒图标的菜品？不用了，谢谢。多伦多大学的心理学家保罗·布鲁姆表示，尽管我们的天性是避免这些体验，但我们的大脑可能也天生倾向于寻找它们。保罗·布鲁姆，欢迎来到“隐藏的大脑”。很高兴来到这里，尚卡尔。很期待今天的交流。保罗，我们刚刚听了一位名叫詹姆斯的男士讲述他年少时违背常理，和死党在商场裸奔的故事。现在，我假设
you've never gone streaking yourself, but you have engaged sometimes in doing things that were unpleasant. Like what, Paul? I have, and I bet you have too. I eat spicy food, I eat food so hot it makes me sweat and makes me uncomfortable. I go on social media, I think this is going to make me upset. I read it, it makes me upset but I do it and then I do it over and over again. I watch movies that frighten me, I look at things that repel me. Even in little examples, like a lot of people, I don't like the feeling of velvet. I just, it makes people, it's a scrunch up. People could see me, they'd see me, I'm all scrunched.
你从来没有自己去裸奔过，但你有时也做过一些令人不快的事情。比如什么，保罗？我做过，我敢打赌你也是。我吃辣的食物，我吃的食物辣到让我流汗，让我感到不舒服。我刷社交媒体，心想这会让我心烦意乱。我读了它，它让我心烦意乱，但我还是这么做了，然后我一遍又一遍地这样做。我看吓人的电影，我看让我反感的東西。哪怕是在一些小事上，就像很多人一样，我不喜欢天鹅绒的触感。我只是，它让人们，它会让人起鸡皮疙瘩。如果别人看到我，他们会看到我，我全身都缩成一团。
And yet, when I see velvet furniture, I can't resist running my hand over it and going, oh man, well, my wife looks at me and laughs. And so I find this fascinating. You know a very simple story of human nature is that we seek out pleasure and avoid pain and I'm interested in counter examples where we sometimes avoid pleasure and seek out pain. You know some time ago one of my friends was growing some peppers in their backyard
然而，当我看到天鹅绒家具时，我总是忍不住把手伸过去抚摸，然后说，天哪，我的妻子看着我笑了。所以我发现这很迷人。你知道，关于人性最简单的说法是，我们追求快乐，逃避痛苦，而我对反例很感兴趣，在这些反例中，我们有时会逃避快乐，追求痛苦。你知道，前段时间我的一位朋友在他们的后院种了一些辣椒，
and it turned out these were called ghost peppers. These are one of the spiciest peppers that have ever been grown on the planet. And I just couldn't resist, you know, cooking something with it and trying it out. And in fact, just cooking it was so difficult and so unpleasant because I was in these intense coughing spasms. You know, I could barely breathe. It was so spicy. Was so difficult and so unpleasant because I was in these intense coughing Spasms, you know, I could barely breathe it was so spicy and yet there was a part of me that said I have to try this We're drawn to that sort of thing. So so there are limits some people won't go near spicy foods Even somebody like you who will try ghost peppers. You probably have a limit and to what you'll try So we we like some degree control. And I think the control is really important to keep in mind
结果发现这些被称为鬼椒。这是地球上培育出的最辣的辣椒之一。我实在忍不住，你知道，用它做了点东西并尝试了一下。事实上，光是烹饪它就非常困难，也非常令人不快，因为我当时陷入了剧烈的咳嗽痉挛中。你知道，我几乎喘不过气来。它太辣了。非常困难且非常令人不快，因为我陷入了剧烈的咳嗽痉挛中，你知道，它太辣了，以至于我几乎无法呼吸，然而我内心深处有一个声音说，我必须尝尝这个。我们会被这类事情吸引。所以，所以是有限度的，有些人绝不碰辛辣食物，即使像你这样会尝试鬼椒的人，对于你愿意尝试的东西大概也是有限度的。所以我们喜欢某种程度的控制。我认为在讨论这些事情时，牢记控制这一点非常重要。我们喜欢掌控全局。但在这种控制到位的情况下，我们接着会去寻找那些将我们推向极限的体验。它们挑战我们对痛苦的忍耐力，就像鬼椒一样。它们挑战我们对尴尬和羞耻的忍耐力，就像你的裸奔者一样。在某些情况下，它们在道德方向上推动我们，
when we talk about these things. We like to know what we're doing. But with this control in place, we then seek out experiences that push us to the limits. They push our tolerance for pain, as in the ghost pepper. They push our tolerance for embarrassment and shame, as in your streaker. And in some cases, they push us in moral directions
去做那些让我们在道德上感到困扰的事情。它们在心理痛苦方面推动我们。你听一首歌，比如我听阿黛尔的歌，很爱阿黛尔，但它让我难过。如果我本来就很伤心，它们会让我流一点眼泪。所以我们为什么要做这些事情，真是一个绝妙的谜题。因此，当你开始观察时，你会到处看到这种现象的变体。
to doing things that trouble us morally. They push us with regard to sort of psychological pain. You listen to a song, like I listen to Adele, love Adele, but it makes me sad. And if I'm sad anyway, they tear up a little bit. So it's such a neat puzzle why we do these things. So when you start to look, you see versions of this phenomenon everywhere.
你知道，发生车祸时交通会变慢，因为人们想要伸长脖子去看一眼可怕的事情。这里有一段混合武术格斗家凯瑞·斯特拉采访另一位综合格斗选手乔什·罗森布拉特的剪辑。能够去揍别人的脸并享受被人揍脸的感觉，确实需要一种特殊的人类，因为到头来，倒不是说你真的喜欢它，而是
You know, traffic slows down when there's a car crash because people want a rubber neck and get a glimpse of something awful. Here's a clip of the mixed martial arts fighter, Keri Stellar, interviewing another MMA fighter, Josh Rosenblatt. It definitely takes a special kind of human being to punch people in the face and to enjoy being punched in the face because at the end of the day, not that you like love it, but
我的意思是，其中一定有某种享受的因素，才能让你走到那一步，走上擂台。我的意思是如果你挨了一顿打，那就是挨了一顿打。是的，不，你必须有点喜欢它。你必须有点喜欢挨耳光或被人打脸。你觉得他说“你必须有点喜欢被人打脸”是在夸大其词吗，保罗？我不这么认为。我认为这很复杂。所以他会是一个非常非常糟糕的综合格斗选手，
I mean there has to be some kind of enjoyment factor out of it to be able to get there, get in there. I mean if you take a beating, you take a beating. Yeah, no, you got to kind of like it.. You have to kinda like getting punched in the face. Do you think he's exaggerating when he says you have to kind of like getting punched in the face, Paul? I don't. I think it's complicated. So he'd be a very, very bad MMA fighter
如果他太喜欢被打脸的话。可以推测，他真正应该养成的习惯是喜欢打别人的脸。但这里面确实有些门道。我读过他在另一篇采访中的一段话，他谈到，你知道，当你刚开始时，被人打脸是最糟糕的事情。然后你开始从这种感觉中汲取养分。
if he liked it too much. He presumably, he really should get in the habit of liking punching other people in the face. But there's something to it. I read a passage which he in another interview where he talks about, you know, when you start off, getting punched in the face is the worst thing. And then you sort of start to feed off of it.
这里有一件非常重要的事情，也就是你刚才播放的这段采访完美诠释的，那就是对于许多这类事情，我认为对于我感兴趣的、我们即将讨论的几乎所有痛苦来说，它必须是自愿的。我不怀疑当他在擂台里挨了打时，他会说，
And here's one thing which is really important, which this interview you just played really illustrates, which is for a lot of these things, I think for just about all of the suffering that I'm interested in, we're gonna talk about, it has to be voluntary. I don't doubt that when he's in a ring and gets hit in the face, he says,
这才是动真格的，这就是我来到这里的意义。这激励着他。但如果他正排队买电影票，有人跑过来啪地给他一巴掌，那就完全没有这种感觉了。如果你在烹饪鬼椒并吃掉它们，你流着泪，流着汗等等，但那是你自己放进去的，那是另一回事。那是快乐、挑战和期待的源泉。
this is the real thing, this is what I'm here for. And it fuels him. But if he's standing in line at the movies and somebody runs up to him and pops him in the face, there's nothing like that at all. If you're cooking the ghost peppers and you're eating them, you're tearing up, you're sweating and everything, but you put that in there, that's one thing. And that's a source of pleasure and challenge and anticipation.
另一方面，如果你正要坐下来吃早晨的燕麦粥，而有人作为恶作剧在里面塞了一些鬼椒，你肯定不会高兴。我写过关于这个的文章，也谈论过这个，有些人会生气，他们说，听着，我过着慢性疼痛的生活，或者这件可怕的事情发生在我身上。你算老几，竟敢告诉我这太棒了？我的回答是，我并没有告诉你这很棒。如果你没有选择它，未经选择的痛苦通常是可怕的。我们现在感兴趣的是那些主动选择的东西。
On the other hand, if you wanted to sit down for your morning oatmeal and somebody stuck some ghost peppers in there as a joke, you're not going to be very happy. I've written about this and I've talked about this and some people get angry and they say, look, I live a life of chronic pain or this terrible thing happened to me. Who are you to tell me this is fantastic? And my answer is I'm not telling you it's fantastic. If you don't choose it, suffering that's unchosen is typically terrible. We're interested now in the chosen stuff.
所以表面上看，这些不同的事情似乎毫无共同之处，你知道，裸奔、摸天鹅绒沙发、盲目狂刷手机、车祸现场伸长脖子看热闹、挨耳光。但你说它们都说明了良性マ索希ズム（良性自虐）的概念。我们在节目中之前采访伟大的心理学家保罗·罗赞时讨论过这一点，保罗，你能解释一下什么是良性自虐吗？是的，这个术语来自保罗·罗赞，他是一位才华横溢的心理学家。良性自虐是指我们在有限的、可控的范围内寻找痛苦和折磨。
So on the surface these different things might seem like they have nothing in common with each other, you know, streaking or touching a velvet sofa, doom scrolling, rubbernecking, getting punched in the face. But you say they all illustrate the idea of benign masochism. We've talked about this on the show before when we featured the great psychologist Paul Rosin, but can you explain what benign masochism is, Paul? Yeah, so this term comes from Paul, who's a brilliant psychologist. And benign masochism is when we seek out pain and suffering in limited controlled extents.
所以，罗赞所说的并不是那些严重损害自己身体或引火自焚的人。他指的是日常生活中的事情。因此，他给出了辛辣食物的例子，非常热的洗澡水。热到你刚进去时会不由自主地退缩，桑拿，冷水浴，诸如此类的各种事情。体力透支，跑步直到你几乎跑不动为止。你的心脏在胸腔里狂跳，
So, Rosen is not talking about people who seriously damaged their body or set themselves on fire. He's talking about everyday stuff. So, he gives examples of spicy foods, really hot baths. So hot, you're just kind of cringing as you get in, saunas, cold baths, various things like that. Exertion, running until you could barely run anymore. Your heart's pounding out of your chest,
你大口喘着粗气。这就是良性自虐，即以不会对身体造成永久性伤害、但能让你震撼的方式寻求低级别的痛苦。罗赞很感兴趣，我也很感兴趣，我们为什么这样做，以及这说明了人类动机的什么特点。所以我想了解我们的大脑是如何被硬编码来寻找这类事情的。为了回答这个问题，你说我们可能首先得看看为什么我们会被硬编码去寻找不愉快的体验。你曾经认识一个研究生，他向你讲述了墨西哥城人们玩的一个
you're breathing in gasps. That's benign masochism, seeking low levels of pain in ways that don't damage your body permanently, but ways that shake you up. And Rosin is interested, and so am I, in why we do this and what it tells us about human motivation. So I want to understand how our brains are wired to seek out things like this. And to answer that question, you say we might first have to look at why we might be wired to seek out unpleasant experiences. You once knew a grad student who told you about an
不寻常的游戏。它叫托克斯。什么是托克斯，保罗？所以托克斯，他写信告诉我，是人们出去聚会时，和朋友在一起，和家人在一起，这些都是管子。你把手放进管子里，然后会受到电击。据我了解，你可以转动旋钮来决定你会受到什么样的电击，人们会比赛看谁能承受最多。对我来说，这是良性自虐的一个超级有趣的案例。
unusual game that people play in Mexico City. It's called Toquez. What is Toquez, Paul? So Toquez, he wrote to me and told me about, is people go out and they're partying, they're with their friends, they're with their family, and these are these tubes. And you put your hands in the tubes and you get an electric shock. And I gather you could turn a dial to determine what kind of electric shocks you get and people compete into how much they could take it. And this to me is a super interesting case of benign masochism.
它具有并非所有良性自虐都具备的一些特征。它是公开的、社交的、有趣的。我认为在这个案例中，并非所有案例，但在本案中，我们从不同方面看到了良性自虐的社会效应。其中一个方面就是，这是一种炫耀的方式。你知道，我儿子，我谈到我儿子扎卡里当他还是个青少年时，他会
It has some features that not all benign masochism has. It's public, it's social, it's fun. And I think in this case, not all cases, but in this case, we see the social effects of benign masochism in different ways. So one way is, it's a way to show off. You know, my son, I talk about my son Zachary when he was a teenager, and he would have,
和他的朋友们聚在一起争论，他会试图把芥末塞进他们的鼻子，看谁能把最多的芥末塞进去。他们会进行互扇耳光的比赛。他们会，作为一种友好、社交的方式，他们会争论，试图把芥末塞进对方鼻子，看看谁能塞得最多。他们会进行互扇耳光的比赛。作为一种友好、社交的方式，看看谁最硬气？谁能承受最多？但另一个超级有趣的事情是，有时
he would get together with his friends and they'd be arguing, he'd be trying to stick wasabi up their noses, he would get the most wasabi there. They'd have slapping competitions. They would, as a way to sort of in a friendly, social way, and they'd be arguing, they'd be trying to stick wasabi up their nose and see who can get the most wasabi there. They'd have slapping competitions. As a way to sort of, in a friendly, social way, see who's the toughest? Who can take the most? But another thing which is super interesting is that sometimes
当你和我一起经历一个痛苦的事件时，我们一起在桑拿房里。我们俩都跳进冰冷的水中。我们俩都给自己电击。这把我们拉近了。实际上有很多研究表明，在实验室里这样做，在现实世界中观察，共同的痛苦比共同的快乐更能把人们凝聚在一起。
when you and I experience a painful event together, we're both in a sauna together. We both dive into the ice cold water. We both zap ourselves. It brings us together. And there's actually a lot of studies suggesting, doing this in a laboratory, looking at it out in the world, that shared pain, more than shared pleasure,
共同的痛苦把人们凝聚在一起。我想起有一次我和一个朋友去新英格兰的海里游泳，当时还是冬天，水非常非常非常冷。我几乎无法站在那里，太痛苦了。但现在当你谈到它时，我仍然能清晰地记起那一幕，保罗，因为和朋友站在那里的记忆实际上是一个建立羁绊的时刻。我在书中讲了这个故事，关于我的一个朋友，
shared pain brings people together. Every pain brings people together. I'm thinking about a time when a friend and I went swimming in the ocean in New England and it was still winter and the water was very, very, very cold. I could barely stand there and it was so painful. But yet I remember that so vividly now as you're talking, Paul, because the memory of standing there with my friend was in fact a bonding moment. I tell this story in my book of this friend of mine
她和朋友在英国徒步旅行时迷路了。他们迷路了，天色渐黑，他们很冷，也没有食物，没有水，他开始非常担心。然后他们正好撞见一个小镇的正中央，一家酒吧。大约一个小时后，他们坐在酒吧外面，喝着啤酒，吃着炸鱼薯条，
who was hiking in England with a friend and they got lost. And they got lost and it was getting dark and they were cold and he didn't have any food, he didn't have any water, he was getting really worried. And then they ended up pumping right in the middle of a small town, of a pub. And like an hour later, sitting outside in a pub, they're drinking beer, eating fish and chips,
他们在大笑。这是她告诉我的经历，这发生在大概 20 年前，她告诉我这件事。天哪，那真是一次棒极了的经历。嗯，如果他们只是度过了一个普通的下午，玩得很开心，看了一些风景，然后去了酒吧，就不会有这种力量了。共同的苦难确实将我们紧密联系在一起。
they're laughing. And this is an experience, she told me this, this happened like 20 years ago, she told me this. Man, that was a great experience. Well, if they just had a normal afternoon, had a lot of fun, saw some sights, and then went to the pub, It wouldn't have this force. Shared suffering just really connects us.
我在想，这是否也与詹姆斯告诉我们的关于在商场裸奔的故事有关。他不仅是为了商场里人们的教化（我想是的），而且他是和另外四个死党一起做的。他们一起穿过商场。这对他们来说是一次建立羁绊的经历。
I'm wondering if this might also be connected to the story that James told us about streaking through the mall. Not only was he doing it for the edification, I suppose, of the people in the mall, but he was doing this with four other buddies. They were running through the mall together. This was a bonding experience for them.
我想独自裸奔可能一点意思也没有。你会想和你的死党一起裸奔。这种事情也会以其他方式出现。它出现在宗教仪式中。所以我的朋友迪米特里斯·伊吉拉塔斯谈到了涉及痛苦的研究和仪式。他谈到了毛里求斯的一个印度教节日，人们走过热炭，
I think streaking alone is probably no fun at all. You want to streak with your buddies. And this sort of thing shows up in other ways. It shows up in religious rituals. So my friend, Dimitri Igilatas, talks about studies, rituals that involve pain. He talks about this Hindu festival they have in Mauritius, where people walk over hot coals
尖锐的穿刺物刺穿他们的脸颊和舌头。他们的身体上挂着钩子，然后这些钩子连接到战车上。男人们会在下午花几个小时把这些战车拉到山顶。这一切听起来，听起来，你知道，让人难以忍受，像我这样的人几乎听不下去。
and they have skewers plunge through their cheek and their tongues. They have hooks dug into their body and then the hooks are attached to chariots. And the men will spend hours in the afternoon dragging these chariots up to the top of a hill. And this all sounds, it sounds, you know, barely, somebody like me could barely listen to it.
但它产生了所有这些效果。它把人们凝聚在一起。对于参与其中的年轻男性来说，它提高了他们在社区中的地位。它增加了他们对女性的吸引力。他做过研究发现，如果你和社区一起观看这一幕，看到人们为你的宗教、为你的社区忍受痛苦，
But it has all of these effects. It brings people together. For the young men who do it, it increases their standing in the community. It increases how attractive they are to the women. And he has done research finding that if you watch this, with a community, you see people suffer for your religion, for your community,
你会变得更愿意为社区捐款，你更关心它，这把人们凝聚在一起。几个月前，迪米特里斯曾做客“隐藏的大脑”，我记得在谈话快结束时他告诉我，有一次，我不认为这发生在毛里求斯，我想是在另一个地方，但他花了很多时间在这个地方并了解了当地人，他们也有一个走火炭的仪式。到了那个重大的夜晚，你知道，有人转向他并基本上说，好了，现在
you become more willing to give money to the community, you care more about it, it brings people together. We had Dimitris on Hidden Brain some months ago, and I remember him telling me toward the end of our conversation that at one point, I don't think this was in the Mauritius, I think it was in another location, but he had spent a lot of time in this place and gotten to know the people and they also had a fire-walking ritual. And on the big night, you know, someone turned to him and basically said, okay, it's now
轮到你了。他实际上不得不走过这些木炭。当然，他内心深处有一个声音说，你知道，这对一个人类学家来说可不是什么明智的举动，但周围也有所有的社会压力，他说一旦他做到了，这改变了他的感受以及他与周围人的连接。是的，是的。我的意思是，这就是人类学家和心理学家的区别。
your turn. And he had to actually walk across these schools. And of course, there was a voice inside him that said, you know, this is not a smart thing for, you know, an anthropologist to be doing, but there was also all of the social pressure around him and he says that once he did it, it transformed the way he felt and his connections with the people around him. Yeah, yeah. I mean, that's the difference between an anthropologist and a psychologist.
我坐在办公室里读到这些，我还以为自己读这些硬核内容显得非常勇敢呢。而迪米特里斯则是亲自去践行。所以做痛苦或尴尬事情的一个原因，是它们让我们看起来很强悍，或者把我们和他人连接起来。另一个原因可能与对比的概念有关。跟我讲讲你小时候在魁北克铲雪的经历吧。哦，这是一个，这是一个美好的童年记忆。
I'll sit in my office and I'll read about it and I think I'm very brave for reading this heavy duty stuff. And Demetri goes and he does it. So one reason to do painful or embarrassing things is they make us look tough or they connect us to others. Another reason might have to do with the idea of contrast. Tell me about your experience shoveling snow as a child in Quebec. Oh, this is a, this is this fond childhood memory.
其实很简单。我敢打赌每个听众都做过类似的事情。我会出去铲雪，我们那会下雪。我来跟你讲讲这个故事，真的。我会铲人行道，我会铲车道。我会变得很冷。然后我回到屋里，我妈妈会给我做一些热可可，还会给我放一浴缸水。
And it's actually very simple. I bet everybody listening has done something like this. But I'd go out and we would get snow. I'll tell you the stories, really. And I'd shovel the walk and I'd shovel the driveway. And I'd get nice and cold. And then I'd come in and my mom would make me some hot cocoa and she'd make me a bath.
然后我坐在浴缸里，我妈妈会给我做一些热可可，还会给我放一浴缸水，我说不坏，我会非常高兴。这背后的逻辑是，有时我们会遭受痛苦，这听起来可能很奇怪，但有时我们受苦是因为痛苦的结束——那种我们离开寒冷进入浴缸的对比——感觉太棒了。这是一个老掉牙的笑话，我父亲讲的一个烂笑话，关于一个人用头撞路灯柱。当被问及他为什么这么做时，
And I'd sit in the bath mom would make me some hot cocoa and she'd make me a bath and I said no bad and I would be so happy and There's a logic to this Which is that sometimes we suffer and this might sound really strange But sometimes we suffer because the end of suffering the contrast where we get out of the cold and into the bath It feels so good. It's this dumb joke my father, dumb joke he tells about the guy who's banging his head against a lamppost. And when asked why he does it,
他说，当我停下来的时候，感觉太棒了。我很高兴你喜欢它，或者你在假装喜欢它来讨好我。你不该纵容我父亲讲这些烂笑话。但在某种程度上，我认为我们经常寻找不快，因为从不快中解脱出来的感觉太棒了。在你徒步旅行或露营三天之后，没有什么比洗个热水澡、洗个热水淋浴更好的了。在你经历了桑拿房的高温烘烤之后，没有什么比跳进清凉的芬兰湖水更爽的了。所以其中一部分是对比。实验室研究发现，如果一个中性体验前面伴随着一个痛苦的体验，你就会觉得这个本该是中性的体验感觉很好。我们的大脑是靠对比运作的。我们体验的一切都是相对的，无论浴缸里的水感觉是热还是冷，
he says, it feels so good when I stop. And I'm glad you like it, or you're being nice and pretending to like it. You shouldn't humor my father of these dumb jokes. But in some way, I think we often seek out unpleasantness because the release from unpleasantness feels so good. There's nothing like a hot bath after you, a hot shower after you've been hiking
取决于它之前的感受，痛苦和快乐也是如此。你知道，我有时听说有人去看脊椎按摩师或按摩师，这些人对他们施加非常剧烈的疼痛，但事后你和他们交谈时，他们会告诉你，这段经历可能很痛苦，但事后他们感到了极乐。
or camping for three days. There's nothing like jumping into the cool finish lake after you've been roasting in a hot sauna. And so some of it is contrast. And there's laboratory studies finding that you could feel a neutral experience, I mean, which normally be neutral, feels good if it was preceded by a painful experience. That our minds work on contrast. Everything we experience is sort of relative, whether or not a bath, water feels hot or cold,
我的意思是，这就是这里的对比理论。没错。没错。而且现在你必须愿意经历痛苦，并且你必须以某种方式在心里算一笔账。我认为我们在潜意识里就是这样做的，权衡一下：痛苦换来最后的解脱值得吗？你知道，我女儿最近开始上大学的大一，就在学期开始前，他们去了一次徒步旅行，那里的条件确实相当原始。他们几乎没有淋浴，露天睡觉，很不舒服，他们呆了三天。
depends on how it felt before, and so too for pain and pleasure. You know, I've sometimes heard people who go to a chiropractor or a massage therapist who subjects them to really intense pain, but when you talk to them afterwards, they'll tell you that the experience may have been painful, but afterwards they felt bliss.
当然，他们经历了这段痛苦期。他们彼此之间的羁绊大大加深了。但随后一开学，他们一回到校园就搬进宿舍，说实话，宿舍条件其实不怎么样。但与他们前三天刚刚经历的事情相比，宿舍简直就像四季酒店。所以他们都搬进去，然后说，天哪，这些宿舍是有史以来最好的东西。我认为学校这招简直是个天才之举，基本上就是让孩子们
I mean, that's the same contrast theory here. That's right. That's right. And a lot of now you have to be willing to go through the pain and you have to in some way do the math. And I think we do this unconsciously figure is the pain worth the relief at the end? You know, my daughter recently started her freshman year at college and right before the term started, they went on this hiking trip, which was really in fairly primitive circumstances. They went very few showers, they were sleeping outdoors, it was uncomfortable, and they spent three days.
在向他们介绍校园住房之前先经历一段痛苦的时期。这相当聪明。如果你靠在树林里捕杀的食物过活，自助餐厅的食物可能也会更好吃。有一个与这个想法相关的研究，考察了人们在一个月的时间里是如何安排时间的，他们经常试图平衡自己的感受，这取决于他们是感觉良好还是感觉糟糕。你能谈谈这项正在进行的研究吗？
And of course, they went through this period of suffering. They bonded with each other tremendously. But then they show up back on campus now as soon as the semester starts and they're moving into their dorms, which are really not that great. But compared to what they had just dealt with the previous three days, the dorms felt like the four seasons. And so they all move in and they say, my God, these dorms are the best things ever. And I thought this was kind of genius on the part of the school to basically put the kids
这是一项非常有趣的研究。研究对象有数万人，他们使用智能手机应用程序来记录人们的活动以及他们在做这些事情时的快乐程度。他们发现人们倾向于根据享乐平衡的原则行事，
through a period of suffering before introducing them to campus housing. It is fairly clever. Probably the cafeteria food tastes better too if you were living off the food you had to kill in the woods or something. There's a study related to this idea that looked at how people spend their time over the course of a month, often trying to balance out their feelings, depending on whether they're feeling good or feeling bad. Can you talk about this work that's being done?
也就是一旦他们做了有趣的事情？他们就会接着做一些没那么有趣的事情。他们就会选择，好吧，现在是时候（你知道的）打扫浴室，或者（你知道的）处理我的纳税申报单了；而当他们做了一些令人不快的事情时，那就会是去进行一次美好的散步、喝一杯威士忌或看一个有趣的电视节目的好时机
It's very interesting research. It was tens of thousands of people and use a smartphone app to record people's activities and how happy they were when they were doing these things. And what they found was that people tended to work on a principle of hedonic balance Which is that once they did something that was fun? They would then do something that was less fun. They would then choose well now it's time to to you know Clean the bathroom or you know work on my taxes and when he did something unpleasant They would then that would be the time to go you know to go for a nice walk or have a whiskey, watch a fun TV show
这是一项非常有趣的研究。研究对象有数万人，他们使用智能手机应用程序来记录自己的活动以及在做这些事情时的快乐程度。研究发现，人们往往遵循享乐平衡的原则，也就是说，一旦他们做了有趣的事情，就会接着去做一些没那么有趣的事情。他们会选择“好吧，现在是时候，你知道的，打扫浴室，或者，你知道的，处理我的税务了”。而当他们做完不愉快的事情之后，那就会是时候，你知道的，去散个步，或者喝杯威士忌，看个有趣的电视节目。
or something like that. They would hold their life in balance. And I think this sort of hedonic contrast is really interesting. It says that we often seek out these contrasting experiences. It might be that after a difficult experience, a pleasurable experience is all the more pleasurable. And that might push them in that direction.
或者类似的。他们会让生活保持平衡。我认为这种享乐对比真的非常有趣。它表明，我们经常会去寻找这些对比强烈的体验。也许在经历了一段艰难的经历之后，快乐的体验会变得更加快乐。这可能会推动他们朝着这个方向发展。
But isn't it interesting, Paul, that it's not just that we do something difficult and then we seek a reward or we seek a treat, but sometimes if we've had a lot of treats and a lot of rewards, we actually might be interested in saying, okay, let me try my hand at doing something difficult. So the scales balance in both directions. I think so and I think there's a few different things going on here one is
但保罗，这难道不是很奇妙吗？我们做了一件艰难的事情，然后去寻求回报或犒赏，这不仅仅是这样；有时候，如果我们已经有了很多犒赏和回报，我们其实可能会想：好吧，让我来尝试做点困难的事情。所以天平是在两个方向上保持平衡的。我想是的，我觉得这里面有几个不同的因素，其中之一就是
What psychologists call the hedonic treadmill? Which is after a while having a good time you get bored with it You know you habituate is the term we use and so you need to switch off and do something else now one thing you could Do is find a different pleasurable activity that scratches a different itch, but it might be time then to recognize I'm getting diminishing returns from my pleasurable experiences. There are taxes to be done. Now is the time to do them. When we come back, how we sometimes seek out unpleasant things in order to punish ourselves. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
心理学家所说的“享乐跑步机”。也就是说，在经历了一段时间的好时光后，你就会对它感到厌倦。你知道，我们用“习惯化”这个词来形容，所以你需要转移注意力去做别的事情。现在，你可以做的一件事是寻找另一种能挠到不同痒处、带来不同快乐的活动，但也许这时候你也该意识到，从这些快乐体验中获得的收益正在递减。还有税要报。现在是时候去做了。接下来的节目中，我们将探讨为什么我们有时会为了惩罚自己而寻找不愉快的事物。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
Psychologist Paul Bloom is the author of The Sweet Spot, The Pleasures of Suffering and the Search for Meaning. He says there are many reasons we seek out perverse pleasures. We seek attention, we wish to experience the contrast between pain and pleasure, and sometimes we just like the challenge of it. Paul, you told me about your son Zachary when he was a teenager, but when he was four years old, he was watching a cartoon one day and it had a violent chase scene in it. How did he respond to this? So he began, and I should tell you, I have his consent to use these stories.
心理学家保罗·布鲁姆是《甜头：痛苦的快乐与对意义的追寻》一书的作者。他说，我们寻求那些反常的快乐有很多原因。我们寻求关注，我们希望体验痛苦和快乐之间的对比，有时我们只是喜欢其中的挑战。保罗，你跟我讲过你儿子扎卡里小时候的故事，当他四岁的时候，有一天他在看一部动画片，里面有一个暴力的追逐场景。他是怎么反应的？所以他开始——我得说明一下，我有他的同意来分享这些故事。
He's in his 20s now and he still, he rolls his eyes a bit but I could tell these stories. He was, there was different cartoon characters chasing each other, the sort of thing you and I would watch and be fine, but he was a kid and he got scared. He started to cry a little bit and he'd shake a little bit, getting really upset.
他现在二十多岁了，虽然还是会有点翻白眼，但我还是可以讲这些故事。当时，有不同的卡通角色在互相追逐，这种场景你我看了都会觉得很正常，但他当时是个小孩子，他被吓到了。他开始哭了一小会儿，还有点发抖，变得非常难过。
And I said, hey, Zach, don't worry, man. I'll turn it off. So I reached to shut it off, and he yells at me. He said, don't turn it off. Leave it on. And then he stares at me, and he's kind of crying and being upset. And I think there's something very human in that,
我说，嘿，扎克，别担心，伙计。我把它关掉。于是我伸手去关电视，结果他对我大喊大叫。他说，别关！留着它。然后他盯着我，一边哭一边有些难过。我觉得这其中包含着一种非常人性的东西，
where if you and I were watching a horror movie together or a thriller, and we're just like, oh, this is extremely heart pounding, very stra, and then somebody said, oh, don't worry guys, I'm gonna shut it off. We'd say, I mean, why are you doing that? What are you doing? We're enjoying this.
就像你和我一起看恐怖片或惊悚片时，我们会觉得“天哪，这太让人心跳加速了，太刺激了”，然后有人说，“噢，别担心，伙计们，我要把它关了。”我们会说：“我的天，你为什么要这么做？你在干什么？我们正看得高兴呢。”
And maybe we paid to see it. And that's a sort of paradox. Why are experiences that are normally negative, like being afraid, become pleasurable in the context of fiction? If you're sitting in your house alone, and it's the middle of the night, and you think you're alone,
而且也许我们还花钱买了票。这就产生了一种悖论。为什么在虚构的情境中，那些通常是负面的体验（比如感到害怕）会变得令人愉快？如果你一个人坐在家里，正值半夜，你以为只有你一个人，
and all of a sudden you hear footsteps, that would be the worst thing you could imagine. Your heart would be pounding out of your chest, and that would not be fun. But you'll watch a movie where that happens to another character and maybe your heart's pounding a bit. Anyway, but this is fantastic. This is great.
突然你听到一阵脚步声，那将是你能想象到的最糟糕的事情。你的心会紧张得快跳出胸膛，那可一点都不好玩。但如果是在电影里看到另一个角色遭遇这种事，也许你的心也会怦怦直跳，但你会觉得：不管怎样，这太棒了！这太好了！
What's gonna happen next? And I think fiction is an extremely clever invention. There's a lot of reasons why we like stories. But one of the reasons, which is what we're zooming in now, it connects to our theme, is that it offers us tension and fear, but it's entirely safe. I'm wondering if there's also an element of predictability about it. There are some forms of fiction and some movies that have sequels to them that in fact are very predictable. If you watch the Die Hard movie sequence, for example, what happens in Die Hard and Die Hard 2 and Die Hard 3,
接下来会发生什么？我认为虚构作品是一项极其聪明的发明。我们喜欢故事有很多原因，但其中一个原因——也是我们现在要聚焦的、与我们主题相关的点——是它为我们提供了紧张感和恐惧感，但它完全是安全的。我想知道这里面是否也包含着一种可预测的元素？有些形式的虚构作品和电影有续集，事实上它们是非常可预测的。例如，如果你看《虎胆龙威》系列电影，在《虎胆龙威》、《虎胆龙威2》和《虎胆龙威3》中会发生什么？
fundamentally the plot is not changing. What does that do for us as we are watching things that are very dramatic and perhaps even stressful or thrilling, but we kind of know where it's all going to end up? That's right. And you know, you've had kids. You know, one of the agonies of having kids is reading Go Dog Go for the 10,000th time. Because at first, kids are sensitive creatures. And at first, they hear a story. And it's often going to be too tense for them to sort of cope with.
从根本上讲，剧情并没有改变。当我们观看那些非常戏剧化、甚至可能充满压力或刺激，但我们又大概知道结局会走向何方的作品时，这对我们有什么影响？确实如此。你知道的，你也有过孩子。抚养孩子的一大痛苦之一就是第一万次读《Go Dog Go》。因为一开始，小孩子是敏感的生物。起初，当他们听到一个故事时，通常会觉得太紧张而难以应付。
So they say, read it again. Read it again. Read it again. Tell me the part again. And there's a tremendous safety. and know what's going to happen. And the bad parts of the excitement fade away and the good parts are intact. I mean, in some ways, it's almost as you're describing this, it's almost like a form of, you know, exposure therapy. I mean, kids are not quite psychiatrists, but that's kind of what they're doing, right?
所以他们会说：再读一遍。再读一遍。再读一遍。把那部分再讲给我听听。这里面有一种巨大的安全感，而且知道了会发生什么。兴奋感中那些不好的部分褪去了，好的部分保留了下来。我的意思是，在某种程度上，当你这样描述时，它几乎就像是一种……你知道的，暴露疗法。我的意思是，小孩子们虽然算不上精神病学家，但这正是他们在做的事，对吧？
When they're basically saying, expose me to this scary thing over and over and over again, and after some time, it starts to just become a thing I can enjoy rather than something that terrifies me. You know, I never thought of it that way, but I think that's a deep point. I've always been interested in the idea that, for adults at least, our Love of fiction is motivated by desire to experience worst-case scenarios, which is why we don't just
当他们基本上是在说“一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地让我暴露在这个可怕的东西面前”，过了一段时间后，它开始变成了一件我可以享受的事情，而不是一件让我感到恐惧的事情。你知道的，我从来没有从这个角度想过，但我觉得这是一个深刻的观点。我一直对这样一个想法很感兴趣：至少对成年人来说，我们对虚构作品的热爱是由体验最坏情况的渴望所驱动的，这就是为什么我们不仅
Appreciate happy fiction. We we appreciate fiction where everything goes to hell zombie movies and war movies and movies of relationships that end up, you know in pieces and You wonder why why don't we just watch happy things? And one answer is because we wanna prepare ourselves for bad things. And one way to do so is to go over it in our head as a sort of simulation,
欣赏大团圆的虚构作品。我们也欣赏那些一切都陷入混乱的虚构作品——丧尸电影、战争电影，以及那些最后支离破碎的情感电影。你会纳闷：为什么我们不只看快乐的东西呢？其中一个答案是，我们想为不好的事情做好准备。而做到这一点的方法之一就是在脑海中将其作为一种模拟来反复经历，
just like you might use a flight simulator to simulate what's gonna happen if you're flying and one of your engines fails. The idea of that exposure could be part of this process is a good one. Maybe there are things in your life which you're gonna experience sooner or later and fiction toughens you up.
就像你可能会用飞行模拟器来模拟你在飞行时如果其中一个引擎发生故障会发生什么一样。这种暴露疗法可能是这个过程的一部分，这个想法很好。也许你生命中迟早会经历一些事情，而虚构作品能让你变得坚强。
It gives you a little taste of what it is so that when it really happens, you're in a better position to deal with it. Do you think the same thing is at work when it comes to the fantasies we have? Many of us of course have pleasurable and pleasant fantasies, but lots of us also report having unpleasant fantasies. Now when it comes to a fantasy, we're the scriptwriter, we're the director, it's a
它让你对现实有一个初步的体会，这样当真正发生时，你就能处于更有利的地位去应对它。你认为在我们拥有的幻想中，是否也存在着同样的机制？我们许多人当然会有令人愉快的、美好的幻想，但我们中也有很多人报告说有不愉快的幻想。说到幻想，我们是编剧，我们是导演，这是我们在自己脑海中制作的一部
movie that we're making in our own heads. Why do you think we come up with fantasies that are unpleasant or scary? Yeah I think that's exactly is exactly the same sort of process. So you might be going for a walk and instead of filling your head with happy thoughts or fantasies about awards and great riches and true love, you say, what if my wife left me? What if I got fired? What if something happened to my kids? There are studies which sample what people think about day to day. so you're walking around
电影。你认为为什么我们会产生那些令人不愉快或可怕的幻想呢？是的，我认为这完全是同一个过程。所以你可能在散步，脑子里想的不是快乐的想法，也不是关于奖品、巨大财富和真爱的幻想，而是说：如果我妻子离开我了怎么办？如果我被解雇了怎么办？如果我的孩子出了什么事怎么办？有一些研究会对人们日常的所思所想进行采样。所以你走在路上，
and a beeper goes off on your phone. You write down what you're thinking about. And to a surprising extent, over half the time, when you're free to think about anything you want in the world, people's minds go negative. And we think about bad things. And I think that this in some way makes our life less pleasurable,
手机上的蜂鸣器响了。你写下你当时正在想的事情。在惊人的程度上，超过一半的时间里，当你可以自由地去想世界上任何你想的事情时，人们的思绪都会走向消极。我们会去想不好的事情。我认为这在某种程度上让我们的生活变得不那么快乐，
but it makes adaptive sense. There's no value in you imagining what you're going to do if you win a great prize. Because you stand up and accept a great prize. Good things typically are really easy to deal with. But what happens if your relationship is destroyed, if your government falls apart, if people attack you, that's the sort of thing where it really pays to think about, even if it makes our life quite a bit less pleasant. The psychotherapist and podcaster Esther Perel
但从适应的角度来看是有意义的。想象如果你赢得了一个大奖你会怎么做，这没有什么价值。因为你只要站起来接受大奖就行了。美好的事情通常真的很容易处理。但是，如果你的关系破裂了，如果你的政府崩溃了，如果有人攻击你，这种时候，花心思去思考才是真正有价值的，即使这会让我们的生活变得不那么愉快。心理治疗师兼播客主持人埃丝特·佩瑞尔
talks about the idea that sometimes the fantasies we have, including the sexual fantasies we have, are often at odds with our own values and proclivities. So in other words, we have fantasies about things that in fact are at odds with what we actually want to happen to us in real life. And I'm wondering if that's actually a manifestation of what you just talked about, which is when you're going for the walk and you imagine your child being kidnapped, you're not actually asking for your child to be kidnapped. You're just exploring what that would be like and trying to figure out what you
谈到了这样一个观点：有时我们拥有的幻想，包括我们的性幻想，往往与我们自身的价值观和倾向相悖。换句话说，我们对某些事情产生幻想，而这些事情实际上与我们在现实生活中真正希望发生在我们身上的事情相矛盾。我想知道这是否正是你刚才谈到的那种现象的体现：当你去散步并想象你的孩子被绑架时，你其实并不是在请求让你的孩子被绑架。你只是在探索那种情况下会是什么样，并试图弄清楚你在那种情况下会做什么。
would do in that circumstance. I think that's exactly right. There are studies on what people seek out in pornography and what they do with the fantasies that they have. And to a surprising extent, people and more often women have fantasies about violence and bad treatment but what's really important to keep in mind is in some sense are fantasies and that you're thinking about them but it's not what they want in fact
我认为完全正确。有一些关于人们在色情作品中寻求什么以及他们如何处理自己的幻想的研究。在惊人的程度上，人们——而且更多是女性——对暴力和虐待抱有幻想，但真正重要的是要记住，在某种意义上，这些只是幻想，你在思考它们，但这并不是他们想要的。事实上，
they're they're having these things run through head exactly because it's what they don't want but they have to worry about more than men have to worry about so our mind will often reenact things that are our own worst-case scenarios. Can you talk about the idea that some of our interest in in in playing with unpleasant experiences has to do with play that you know when kids for example use their imaginations to come up with games they often involve you know horrific scenarios being chased by a monster being eaten by a lion they also include the possibility of injury, for example, kids play fight, for example. Talk about how games can sometimes be
这些事情之所以在他们脑海中盘旋，恰恰是因为这是他们不想要的东西，但也是他们比男性更需要担忧的事情。因此，我们的大脑经常会重演那些我们最担心的最坏情况。你能谈谈这样一个观点吗：我们对把玩不愉快体验的部分兴趣与“游戏”有关？你知道，比如当孩子们发挥想象力来设计游戏时，通常会涉及可怕的场景——被怪物追赶、被狮子吃掉，它们还包括受伤的可能性，比如孩子们会进行模拟打斗。请谈谈游戏有时如何会变得
unpleasant and painful, Paul. It gets at the theory we've been talking about from a different direction. So evolutionary biologists have long asked the question, why do animals, including humans, play? Like, it seems like, you know, you spend your time learning about the world and establishing social relationships and, you know, accumulating resources, but instead, we chase each other with toy guns or we go watch football.
不愉快和痛苦，保罗。这从另一个方向切入了我们一直在讨论的理论。因此，进化生物学家长期以来一直在问这样一个问题：为什么包括人类在内的动物要进行游戏？看起来，你似乎应该把时间花在了解世界、建立社会关系以及积累资源上，但相反，我们却拿着玩具枪互相追逐，或者去看橄榄球比赛。
So what's the purpose of play? And I think there's an answer. I think there's actually a really good answer, which is play is a form of safe practice the reason why young animals including young humans play fight is because fighting is a useful skill and one way to get good at any useful skill is to is to practice at it and play is a very clever trick where you go through the practice of what you're trying to do, but in a safe way. And so it's not just talking about people, but like dogs. Dogs play fight.
那么游戏的目的是什么？我想有一个答案。我认为这其实是一个非常好的答案，那就是游戏是安全练习的一种形式。年轻动物（包括人类幼崽）之所以进行模拟打斗，是因为战斗是一项有用的技能，而精通任何有用技能的方法之一就是进行练习。游戏是一个非常聪明的把戏，它让你经历你想要做的事情的练习，但却是以一种安全的方式。所以这不仅适用于人类，也适用于狗。狗狗们会进行模拟打斗。
They have a sort of signal, what they call a play bow, where they communicate to each other, we're going to fight, but it's going to be for fun. We're not going to really hurt each other. And then they proceed with fighting. What makes humans unique, unique then isn't play. A lot of animals play. It's that we play in our heads. And I think everything from video games to horror movies to rumination is a form of safe play.
它们有一种信号，被称为“玩耍鞠躬”，通过这种信号它们相互交流：我们要打架了，但这只是为了好玩，我们不会真的伤害彼此。然后它们继续打斗。那么，使人类变得独一无二的不是游戏。许多动物都会玩游戏。独特之处在于我们在脑海中玩游戏。我认为从电子游戏到恐怖片再到反刍思维，都是安全游戏的一种形式。
We reenact these things that we wanna get good at, like combat or planning or fighting, that sort of thing. I want to play you a clip from the TV show, Fear Factor. You guys are each going to have to stick your head inside this box with these 50 tarantulas for three minutes. And if you don't think that you can remain absolutely motionless for three minutes I want you guys to back out now because besides their eight legs each one of these tarantulas has two huge fangs and all of their venom so this task involves covering yourself in tarantulas now the participants are trying to win a prize Paul but as viewers we are not trying to
我们会重演那些我们想要精通的事情，比如战斗、规划或搏击之类的事情。我想放一段电视节目《惊险大挑战》的剪辑给你听。你们每个人都必须把头伸进这个装着50只狼蛛的箱子里，持续三分钟。如果你觉得自己无法在三分钟内保持绝对静止，我希望你们现在就退缩，因为除了八条腿之外，这些狼蛛中的每一只都有两颗巨大的毒牙和它们所有的毒液，所以这项任务包括把狼蛛覆盖在自己身上。现在，参赛者们正努力赢得奖品，保罗，但作为观众，我们并不是在努力
win anything so what's the appeal? Fear Factor had millions of viewers. There must be some of the satisfaction to think, thank God it's not me, it's other people. But I think we have a vicarious interest in saying people push themselves to the limits. Just like we sometimes do it ourselves, both in the real world and in imagination.
赢得什么，那吸引力在哪里呢？《惊险大挑战》拥有数百万观众。这里面一定有一种满足感，觉得“谢天谢地，不是我，是别人”。但我认为，我们有一种代入式的兴趣，想看人们把自己逼到极限。正如我们有时在现实生活和想象中所做的那样，
There's a fascination in watching other people do it. There's a fascination watching other people compete in sports, compete in games, and also put themselves at risk in interesting ways. And maybe it's a kind of vicarious satisfaction that I'm not them, look what they're doing, or maybe even a sense of superiority. But I think the most important cause is just this fascination in seeing worst-case scenarios, what happens when people are put to the limits.
看着别人这样做有一种着迷感。看着别人在体育运动中竞争、在比赛中竞争，并以有趣的方式让自己承担风险，这有一种迷人之处。也许这是一种代入式的满足感：我不是他们，看看他们在做什么，甚至可能带有一点优越感。但我认为最主要的原因是对观察最坏情况的着迷，即当人们被逼入极限时会发生什么。
So in a more serious context, some people take the idea of pain and unpleasant experiences to an extreme and actively subject themselves to self-harm. Some people cut themselves, others subject themselves to intense pain. Some of these things can be extremely dangerous, even life-threatening, and they become medical problems, they become disorders. Can you talk about how this kind of self-harm might also be related to feelings of powerlessness but also feelings of control Paul? So I know less about this. I know less about this sort of pathologies of math not the mani-masochism anymore but the heavy-duty masochism where people will
因此，在一个更严肃的语境下，有些人将疼痛和不愉快体验的想法推向极端，积极地让自己承受自我伤害。有些人割腕，另一些人让自己承受剧烈的痛苦。其中一些事情可能极其危险，甚至危及生命，并演变成医疗问题和心理障碍。你能谈谈这种自我伤害可能如何也与无力感以及控制感有关吗，保罗？我对这方面的了解较少。我对这种病理学了解得不多——不再是多重人格或自虐狂，而是那种人们会对自己造成
seriously harm themselves. Sometimes it's a byproduct of some form of mental illness like schizophrenia and falls very much outside the normal phenomena we're talking about. But there is a connection between these forms of self-harm and the sort of more benign forms of self-harm. One of the connections is they both may be forms of signaling. In some way an adolescent, say cutting herself or harming herself in some other way could be a signal to people, I need help. I need help and my need is so serious. You're not listening to my words and I get that.
严重伤害的重度自虐。有时它是某种精神疾病（如精神分裂症）的副产品，这在很大程度上超出了我们正在讨论的正常现象的范畴。但这些形式的自我伤害与那些更良性的自我伤害形式之间确实存在联系。其中一个联系是，它们都可能是某种发出信号的形式。在某种程度上，一个青春期女孩割腕或以其他方式伤害自己，可能是在向人们发出一个信号：我需要帮助。我需要帮助，我的需求是如此严重。你们没有听进我的话，我明白了。
The words could be fake. The words could be dishonest, but I'm going to damage my body to persuade you that this is serious business. And so one explanation for cutting and other things like that is that it's a cry for help. Another explanation is that there is, almost paradoxically, a sort of anesthesia effect for certain sorts of self-harm. That it takes you out of your body,
言语可能是假的，言语可能是不诚实的，但我将损害我的身体来让你们相信这是一件严重的事情。因此，对割腕和其他类似行为的一种解释是，这是在呼救。另一种解释是，近乎矛盾的是，某些类型的自我伤害具有某种麻醉效应。它能让你抽离出自己的身体，
that the infliction of pain under the right circumstances makes other pains go away. We should note that there are resources and support available for people struggling with cutting and other forms of self-harm. To access those resources you can call or text 988 in the United States at any time of the day or night. in the United States at any time of the day or night. So, Paul, researchers have examined people's propensity to punish themselves after they've done something that violated their own values. Can you describe these studies and what they found? So, it's an old observation that sometimes people hurt themselves
在适当的情况下施加痛苦会让其他痛苦消失。我们应该指出，对于那些正在与割腕和其他形式的自虐作斗争的人来说，有相关的资源和支持可供使用。在美国，无论白天还是黑夜的任何时间，您都可以通过拨打或发送短信 988 来获取这些资源。在美国，无论白天还是黑夜的任何时间。那么，保罗，研究人员调查了人们在违背自身价值观的事情后惩罚自己的倾向。你能描述一下这些研究以及他们的发现吗？这是一个古老的观察结果：有时人们会伤害自己，
because they believe they did something wrong and want to punish themselves. There's a story about Galen, the second century physician. He had a friend of his who beat up severely a slave, and he felt horrible about it. So he went to Galen, went to his house, stripped himself naked, handed him a whip, and said, you have to flog me for my crime. And Galen tried to laugh it off and said,
因为他们认为自己做错了事，想要惩罚自己。有一个关于公元二世纪医生盖伦的故事。他的一个朋友狠狠地殴打了一个奴隶，他为此感到极其内疚。于是他去找盖伦，来到他家，脱光衣服，递给他一根鞭子，说：你必须为我的罪行鞭打我。盖伦试图一笑置之，说道：
oh yeah, you're gonna have to do this. No, you have to flog me. And it might seem like a strange example, but I think we see this impulse in ourselves where when we do something wrong, we're moralizing creatures. This is what I'm very interested in. I studied this in children, I studied this in adults,
噢，行啦，你非得这么做不可吗？不，你必须鞭打我。这看起来可能是一个奇怪的例子，但我认为我们在自己身上也能看到这种冲动：当我们做错事时，我们是有道德感的生物。这也是我非常感兴趣的。我在儿童身上研究过这一点，我也在成年人身上研究过这一点，
our desire to punish wrongdoers. And the most obvious cases are when the wrongdoers are other people, but sometimes the wrongdoers and the most obvious cases are when the wrongdoers are other people but sometimes the wrongdoers are ourselves. So there's now several studies of the form where since you give people some opportunity to hurt themselves in a mild way, give themselves painful shocks, stick their hand in freezing water which is very unpleasant after a while and what these studies find over and over again is that if you tell people ahead of time,
我们惩罚错误制造者的欲望。最明显的例子是当错误制造者是其他人时，但有时错误制造者——最明显的例子是当错误制造者是其他人时，但有时错误制造者是我们自己。因此，现在有几项这样的研究：你给人们一些以温和方式伤害自己的机会，比如给自己一些痛苦的电击，或者把手伸进过一会儿就会非常难受的冰水中。这些研究一遍又一遍地发现，如果你提前告诉人们：
I want you to think about something you did that was wrong. I want you to think of a time when you hurt somebody. People will then inflict more pain on themselves. So the role of morality, the role of a desire to punish wrongness is I think one force that could explain something that goes on in masochistic pleasures. I'm wondering Paul if the same thing might happen on the sports field as well. We've all seen you know athletes who mess up or someone who plays a bad shot in tennis and they get so angry with themselves they want to punch themselves or actively hit themselves. You know again you're
我想让你回想一件你做错了的事。我想让你回想一个你伤害过别人的时刻。人们随后会给自己施加更多痛苦。因此，道德的作用、惩罚错误行为的欲望的作用，我认为是解释马祖金（自虐）快乐中发生的事情的力量之一。保罗，我想知道同样的现象是否也会在运动场上发生。我们都见过那些表现失常的运动员，或者在网球比赛中打出一个烂球的人，他们对自己感到如此愤怒，以至于想捶打自己或主动击打自己。你知道，这同样是
inflicting pain on yourself but it's the same kind of thing. How could you have made this mistake? I'm punishing you for making this terrible mistake. It's exactly the same process. I've seen it many times, and once or twice, you know, I've kind of smacked myself and I say, dummy, how did you do that? And I think it's almost a mystery
在给自己施加痛苦，但这是同一种性质的事情。你怎么能犯这种错误？我惩罚你犯了这个可怕的错误。这完全是同一个过程。我见过很多次，而且有一两次，你知道的，我也曾拍打过自己并说：笨蛋，你怎么能那样做？我认为这几乎是一个谜，
why it doesn't happen more often. I mean, think about how we wanna punish people who mess up, are cruel or indifferent in real life. Doesn't it make sense that when we see that we ourselves are lazy or cruel or indifferent, we want to punish ourselves? We want to sort of treat ourselves badly the way we think we should be treated. Now, as I'm saying this, it doesn't sound like the most healthy thing in the world. I think in small doses, I think it's fine. I don't think much badly about a tennis player who hits himself on the head with a racket after missing an easy
为什么这种事没有更频繁地发生。我的意思是，想想我们是如何想要惩罚那些在现实生活中搞砸了事情、残酷或冷漠的人的。当我们看到我们自己很懒惰、残忍或冷漠时，我们想要惩罚自己，难道这不合情理吗？我们想要像我们认为自己应该被对待的那样，恶劣地对待自己。现在，当我这么说的时候，这听起来不像是世界上最健康的事情。我认为在小剂量下，我觉得这没问题。对于一个在错失一个简单球后用球拍敲自己头的网球运动员，我不会有什么不好的看法。
shot. I think if it gets taken too far and you start thinking that you're worthless and you want to sort of destroy your own life, that could be awful. But in small, like a lot of things we're talking about, in small doses, I think, is part of a full life. In our companion story on Hidden Brain Plus, we examine how pain and pleasure can intertwine during sex and how, at the extremes, pain and pleasure can start to resemble one another. People who are in intense pleasure, intense happiness,
我认为如果事情走得太远，你开始觉得自己一无是处，并且想要毁掉自己的生活，那可能会很糟糕。但在小范围内，就像我们谈论的许多事情一样，我认为它是充实生活的一部分。在我们《隐藏的大脑Plus》的配套故事中，我们探讨了疼痛和快乐如何在性爱中交织在一起，以及在极端情况下，疼痛和快乐如何开始变得彼此相似。那些处于极度快乐、极度幸福中的人，
they are hard to tell apart from people whose faces are in intense pain. If you're already a subscriber, that episode should be available in this podcast feed right now. It's titled, The Zen of Pain. If you're not yet a subscriber, please go to support.hiddenbrain.org to sign up. If you're using an Apple device, you can go to apple.co slash hiddenbrain. Your subscription gives you access to exclusive episodes. It also helps us build the show.
他们很难与那些面部表情处于极度痛苦中的人区分开来。如果你已经是订阅者，那一集现在应该可以在这个播客动态中收听了。它的标题是《痛苦的禅意》。如果你还不是订阅者，请前往 support.hiddenbrain.org 进行注册。如果你使用的是苹果设备，你可以访问 apple.co 斜杠 hiddenbrain。你的订阅可以让你收听独家剧集，这也帮助我们打造这个节目。
Again, those links are support.hiddenbrain.org or apple.cohiddenbrain.org or apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. Paul Bloom is a psychologist at the University of Toronto. He is the author of The Sweet Spot, The Pleasures of Suffering and The Search for Meaning. Paul, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. This was terrific. If you have follow-up questions for Paul Bloom, and you'd be willing to share those questions
再次重申，这些链接是 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 apple.co 斜杠 hiddenbrain。保罗·布鲁姆是多伦多大学的心理学家。他是《甜头：痛苦的快乐与对意义的追寻》一书的作者。保罗，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你。这太棒了。如果你对保罗·布鲁姆有后续问题，并且愿意与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享这些问题，
with a Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, pain. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm
请在手机上录制语音备忘录并通过电子邮件发送给我们，邮箱是 ideas 艾特 hiddenbrain.org。主题行请写：pain。再次重复那个电子邮件地址是 ideas 艾特 hiddenbrain.org。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保尔、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是
Hidden Brains executive editor. Next week in our two-part mini series about the pain pleasure continuum, why we fantasize about living a life of leisure and why this might be an error. So definitely people, you know, when they think about a future that's desirable, that's fun, enjoyable, it's about relaxation. It's about being lazy. It's about being at the beach and just kind of sitting. So we see this all the time. That's next week on the show. I hope you'll join us.
《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。下周，在我们关于“痛苦-快乐连续体”的两部分迷你系列节目中，我们将探讨为什么我们幻想过着闲暇的生活，以及为什么这可能是一个错误。所以毫无疑问，人们在考虑一个令人向往、有趣、愉快的未来时，往往是关于放松的。是关于变懒的。是关于去海滩然后随便坐坐的。所以我们随时都能看到这种现象。下周节目再见。希望你能加入我们。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。回头见。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。